this is my cousin Tyrell and he will be
controlling the player character
his name is Kanye he's a giant yo
uh dear cousin traditionally a giant is
not a sued by a player it is a chaotic
evil but I want to be a giant yo
are big
oh okay fine
[Music]
Vince I uh I have that quarterly
analysis that you asked for
I had a quarter of Deez Nuts on your
chin
right
it's just that I wanted to review some
of these numbers with you it seems like
our earnings are low against our
original projections
Deez Nuts were low against your chin
[Music]
you know Vince
if you ever need to talk to me about
something I'm more than happy to listen
nuts will be more than happy to rest
against your chin
[Music]
hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kind of
funny at first these nuts were kind of
funny against your chin
I've been so worried about you
[Music]
I was worried about these nuts on your
chin
this man seriously
these nuts were seriously on your chin
Mr Graham I just got a call from St
Mary's Hospital and your parents were in
a serious car accident
I'm so sorry but your mother is dead
and your father is on life support
[Music]
these nuts were supporting life on your
chin no way
sorry Amber
Vince you gotta stop it
these nuts passed away on your [__] no
they didn't
they didn't Vince
you got to leave here right now and go
be with your dad this could be the last
time that you get to see him it's gonna
be the last time I get to see my knots
on YouTube God damn it Vincent your
father might be dying
these nuts might be dying on your chin
[Music]
God damn it Vince snap the [__] out of
it your mother is dead
[Music]
right
all right
you okay
you're all right you're back
that's all right it was so good
worked in every situation
I know I know and it's always it's just
so funny well it wasn't it wasn't that
funny it was funny
really wasn't that fun events
really funny
I would not go so far as to say it was
really funny Vince
but it wasn't though
it was
like I disagree it's funny okay
one more time it's going to run record
to sing it wasn't really that funny
I gotta see my dad
that was funny wasn't that funny
[Music]
[Applause]
Stay With Me
that I love you
I love
these nuts on your chin
these nuts
[Music]
please no no no
ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
what what what's the joke what I don't
get it you shot that damn fool
yeah no I still don't get it hey man
ain't nothing again
this is funny man
do can't snitch now
no fake laugh
huh that's not real
I could tell
oh I think it's really funny no you
don't
look at him sitting there all dead
he was 20 and now he's dead
he's never gonna have a wife of kids now
what are you doing Wife and Kids
that [__] ain't funny
his mom and dad ain't never gonna see
him again no
no
you're ruining it for me okay well I
guess I just don't get it there it's
just that you shot him that's all that's
the whole thing oh okay so oh
dude you don't shoot a dude that's
already dead that's not funny oh
yes I just don't get it
[__] in the Battleground we're gonna
battle rap every day in the month of
February y'all yo I'm your host big
people
this way to my left we got the champion
y'all introduced son yeah what's
happening this your boy Rhino D and I'm
about the front hand
is
right what's up man I'm doing chilling
in the house 100 USDA pure no filler
right here dude okay okay okay yo Dill
lost a toss so you go first okay
gentlemen battle right all right yeah
man here we go you shook son I'm gonna
eat you for breakfast cause I'm a quick
shot I stole a Copperfield from your
girl's dresses
I don't even know man Hey listen man you
can't even win this 100 yard dash but
let me ask you a question what do they
call that a mustache
[Applause]
last night
take it down a little bit
can you take it down a little bit man
come on what are you a horse
the last one
yo what's up dog you know my son is Rich
I'm swimming in simoleons I mean what am
I supposed to do with this miniature
black Napoleon
Timberlands
[Applause]
why are you doing me why would you no
listen
[Applause]
oh yeah you gotta go man
that's right man yo we got a champion
still we got a champion
[Applause]
[Music]
listen listen man yeah I want you to
look out on the on the lake man I just
want you to look out and imagine a place
man where you can do your thing man when
you and I can go and do our thing but
never have to Forfeit yeah you can
scream and shout and shove people back
and forth but we don't never have to
quit Okay but look out on the lake man
look out on the lake no matter what
happens man I start rapping and my rhyme
stays on the floor and I'm turning the
time and no matter what you do you can
push and shove and scream but we'll
never get disqualified
while you're looking at the lake just
give me one more good
[Applause]
uh greetings adventurers greetings
as you all can see here we have a new
traveler in our ranks uh this is my
cousin Tyrell and he will be controlling
the player character
his name is Kanye he's a giant yo
uh dear cousin traditionally uh a giant
is not assumed by a player it is a
chaotic evil but I want to be a giant yo
are big
oh okay fine well Travelers you are
enjoyed on your adventure today by a
giant named Kanye now when last we left
you you were at the Inn of the North
Star at the town of isildor how do you
begin your adventure I want to get some
[__]
wear the club at Isador yeah Tyro This
is highly unusual I think the guys
probably just want to go on the quest
yes I'd like to join Kanye the giant of
this Quest
seriously
all right the two of you enter it's
heard what do you say Kanye the giant
orders Alize
the barkeep I know not of this foreign
beverage of which you speak perhaps you
would enjoy an elded ale no we both want
the LSA I will say does not exist in
this world Connie the giant slaps that
[__] oh
diet attempts to slap the bartender here
the bartender is half Hobbit and very
Nimble so you're going to have to roll
it 18 or above to hit 20. flip slap that
Hobbit off yo okay
gullible cleric would you care to
restrain Katya the giant before the town
guard is called I grab money out of the
register God the cleric is lawful
catheavery would dishonor his Gods amen
the only guys is money and [__] dude
except Kanye the Giants God and uh
I steal some of the money too
okay would you now like to continue your
quest for the lads of caldahar fellas we
came here for [__] where the [__]
at
all right you see a bevy of well-endowed
wedges great I'll grab them [__] and
we all go on my SUV fine Heidi the giant
udar the dwarf and go on the cleric
climb into his SUV with their [__]
and their ill-gotten gains
plus Kanye the giant pushes demo CD in
the season no he doesn't there are no
CDs
do whatever you want
all right I guess I'm the dungeon master
now
the eye of Odin opens up
[Applause]
16 titties fall out yes
[Music]